wow
[Musica]
[Applauso]
no no
[Musica]
a chi non è mai capitato
magari in giovane età di venire a
conoscenza di proverbi detti popolari
spesso tramandati di generazione in
generazione
concetti leggeri quasi folkloristici e
vengono generalmente raccontati con con
tono divertito
chi ha a che fare con il mondo agricolo
sa che la realtà rurale e ricchissima di
queste saggezze ed è molto difficile che
nel corso di una conversazione con un
agricoltore o comunque con una persona
che chi ha vissuto e lavorato per anni
in agricoltura non ne venga utilizzato
uno un detto che ha catturato la mia
attenzione e che vorrei condividere con
voi è il concime fa il foraggio e il
foraggio fa il concime è un concetto
apparentemente semplice che vede come
protagonisti due prodotti iconici del
mondo rurale da una parte il foraggio
che identifica la coltivazione delle
colture foraggiere alimento zootecnico
per eccellenza è componente essenziale
di quello che è la dieta giornaliera dei
nostri animali e dall'altra il concime
in questo caso non declinato alla forma
chimica quella che possiamo acquistare
alla rivendita o al supermercato per
capirci ma la forma organica derivante
dalle deiezioni degli animali allevati e
alimentati grazie al formaggio il gioco
di parole soprattutto se lo pronunciamo
in velocità inizialmente un po ci
distrae dal dal vero messaggio
ripetendolo però un paio di volte si
inizia a realizzare che queste semplici
parole sono collegate a complessi
processi biologici che sono alla base
del funzionamento e della sostenibilità
dei nostri ecosistemi perché questo
beh contrariamente a quanto possiamo
pensare questo concime
un grande valore agronomico ed ecologico
contenendo elevate quantità di elementi
nutritivi utili per le piante ma anche
dei composti organici indispensabili per
i processi microbiologici che si
svolgono all'interno del terreno
portare al campo questo prezioso
materiale organico permette quindi di
non depauperare la sua fertilità e
vitalità mi biologica e di conseguenza
mantenere efficienti livelli produttivi
delle culture tra cui appunto anche gli
stessi foraggi quella tra il foraggio e
il concime e quindi una sorta di dare
avere orchestrato dall'agricoltore e
tutto questo si ripete con una ciclicità
ormai da da millenni infatti le prime
testimonianze di allevamento le abbiamo
né li abbiamo avuti nel neolitico
intorno al 10 mila avanti cristo e che
di fatto contribuito all'evoluzione
dell'agricoltura ma anche a supportare
lo sviluppo di civiltà una ciclicità che
rappresenta quindi una un antico ma
estremamente attuale esempio applicativo
di quella che oggi chiamiamo economia
circolare o circolare coni che spesso la
sentiamo declinata ai processi di
produzione industriale di riconversione
e riciclo e riciclo di rifiuti
certo qui direte l'agricoltura nel corso
degli anni come del resto tutti gli
altri settori con un tv è cambiata
tantissimo siamo passati da piccole
fattorie che miravano a produrre
alimenti per l'autoconsumo di chi ne
faceva parte a delle realtà aziendali in
grado di soddisfare svariate esigenze
alimentari creando supportando
importanti filiere di produzione tutto
questo anche in un contesto produttivo
sempre più attento alla sicurezza
alimentare all'ambiente del benessere
animale
quindi
il detto il concime fa il foraggio e il
foraggio fi concime può essere
considerato ancora valido oggi questo
dare avere
e ancora oggi così rilevante nonostante
le importanti evoluzioni del comparto
agricolo beh la risposta a questa
domanda è sì assolutamente sì anzi la
ricerca e l'evoluzione tecnologica ci
hanno permesso di aumentare le
potenzialità di questo binomio
gli agricoltori gestiscono quest'oggi
questo concime ho molta più efficacia
utilizzano sistemi di distribuzione più
virtuosi che limitano le perdite di
elementi nutritivi
contenuti all'interno ed evitano nel
tempo stesso emissioni e odori in
atmosfera si aiutano inoltre anche con
tecnologie che permettono loro di
comprendere in tempo reale e quello che
è l'effettivo contenuto di elementi
nutrizionali adeguando così il
quantitativo di concime da distribuire
sulla base dell'effettivo valore
nutrizionale con con importanti vantaggi
agronomici ed ambientali ma non è solo
questo da questa circolarità stiamo
ricavando anche moltissime altre potere
che twas ita è possibile ad esempio
produrre più energia attraverso processi
biologici come la digestione anaerobica
che porta alla produzione di energia
elettrica e termica maker esigua un
materiale organico chiamato e c'è stato
che viene utilizzato poi affini
fertilizzanti così come i reflui i
concimi organici da cui si origina
energia ma ma anche biomateriali e
grazie al lavoro al lavoro di batteri
che trasformano il materiale organico in
in acido acetico dal quale
successivamente verranno estratti dei
dei polimeri di biopolimeri
cosa dire quindi l'agricoltura è stato
oggetto di importanti evoluzioni nel
corso degli anni e ha fattivamente
contribuito anche a far evolvere tanti
altri comparti e settori economico
produttivi a rivoluzioni però non hanno
mai alterato o sostituita la centralità
dei processi biologici su cui proprio
essa si basa da millenni da questa
circolarità
emerge come la produzione di cibo sia
solo la punta dell'iceberg nell'ambito
delle potenzialità dell'agricoltura
bio energia
biomateriali servizi ecosistemici
mantenimento del territorio e riduzione
delle emissioni di carbonio potranno in
futuro
sempre più coesistere con l'obiettivo
alimentare e rispondere alle nuove e
pressanti richieste energetiche e
ambientali di una società in continua
evoluzione
[Musica]
dal foraggio e da il concime perché il
futuro ha radici antiche
[Musica]